no one is talking honestly about about
Iraq and it's very very hard to say what
our responsibilities are given the
unholy or maybe it's holy mess that we
have created in in Iraq we need to shout
help we need to ask for help from the
Europeans we need to open negotiations
with the Iranians we need to be talking
to the Turks but and we need to be
planning our own disengagement but any
will any politician any democratic
politician who claims that we're going
to withdraw from Iraq and the near
future is just lying to the American
people because the Kurds don't want us
to withdraw the Sunni Chiefs don't want
us to withdraw the Shiite government
doesn't want us to withdraw the Saudis
the Kuwaitis the Jordanians the
Egyptians the Israelis and the Turks
don't want us to withdraw and all of
those allies of the United States in the
Middle East are very much afraid of
anything that looks like a defeat for
the United States and a withdrawal on
the schedule that has been proposed by
Obama and Clinton I suppose although
they've given themselves a lot of
loopholes but withdrawal on that
schedule would be a defeat in fact it
might be a route and and so nobody is
going to do that and how to plan a
disengagement because we we have to get
out how to plan a disengagement that
doesn't that doesn't leave everyone that
we have worked with in the Middle East
crying pattern
do that is enormously difficult and none
of the candidates are talking honestly
about those difficult